i'm the associate director of the
institute um
and i i think everybody knows who we are
we're a collaborative research institute
in theoretical computer science
uh and this semester the two programs
that we're running
entirely online are probability geometry
and computation in high dimensions
and the theory of reinforcement learning
and
together they've involved around 200
participants
uh an unusually big number for a a very
unusual semester
so welcome to the final workshop for the
high dimensions program final workshop
for the semester which is on learning
and testing in high dimensions
so a big thank you to our
events coordinator jesse gill for all
his work on the logistics
for this workshop um thanks jesse and
and uh to omid farr who's our
videographer
um and a big thank you to the organizers
to adam clivens uh guy bressler
sebastian bubeck
ninja day and philippe regolay uh
they've done a fantastic job
putting together uh an exciting program
for for this week's workshop i hope you
enjoy the week
and let me hand over to adam to say a
few words about the workshop thanks
peter
thanks to the simons institute for
letting us organize this workshop i know
the organizers and i
had a lot of fun putting it together and
we're really excited for the program
just a very brief overview today is
primarily about
testing it's a learning and testing
workshop but today we'll be focusing
more on testing and property testing
problems
uh tomorrow we'll be uh we'll have a lot
of talks on learning
on graphs and also we'll feature some
you know many hardness results
computational hardness results
uh if you're into neural networks and
deep learning then wednesday is really
your day we'll have
several talks focused on that topic uh
on thursday we'll be looking at a lot of
recent advances
on graphical models both from a
computational and statistical
perspective
and then on friday we'll have a variety
of problems
that are core to kind of computational
statistics and robust learning
so the whole week will be focused on
learning and testing but from
you know varying perspectives and as i
said you know we have an all-star lineup
of speakers beginning with mariam here
thank you so let me um
share um my slides
okay so um thank you today i'm going to
talk about testing
monotone testing monotonicity of
distributions over general pulses
uh this is a joint work uh with tame
scullyakis john people
rene dr benfield and onna kyotpinyani
we routinely model real world data as
random samples from some unknown
distribution
and perform uh inference tasks based on
that
underlying distribution an important
example of such
inference tasks is to understand the
properties
of the underlying distribution this part
these properties can be pretty much
anything
like whether a distribution is uniform
or um
two random variable in our future sets
are independent from each other support
size or the shape of the distribution
distribution testing is basically a
decision
version of this problem so let me
formally define
what it means to test a property
um so the setting of the problem is that
there is an underlying distribution q
which we assume
it's over the domain of one to one
basically n is the domain size
we see bram iid samples from the
distribution queue
and we want to design an algorithm
uh or a tester which can distinguish
whether q
uh is in the set of a distribution that
has the property uh
that have the property or it is in a set
of
epsilon far from having the property um
by that i mean uh for every
for a distribution is called to be
epsilon far
when for every um whichever the distance
uh
is at least epsilon to any distribution
in the
set pi so the goal is to distinguish
these two stats with
high probability and if a distribution
is somewhere in between
either answers are accepted
the main goal in designing tester is to
make sure that they have the optimal
sample complexity
and this is the the sample complexity we
usually
think of a non-asymptotic version
and let me just clarify the term it
means that we want to
find the sample complexity up to
constant factor and
this is in comparison with other fields
that they usually
think about the convergence rate
and other versions of these problems
in the so but we make sure that to find
the sample complexity of the constant
factors and other
efficiency parameters like time
complexity and memory can also be
important after we find the right sample
complexity
several properties have been considered
in the literature and i'm sure that
you're going to see many
more of them in the in the workshop
estimating support size testing whether
distribution is uniform testing whether
it's equal to another distribution
shape of the distribution and many more
have been already
studied so let me
define uh the problem of testing
monotonicity and talk about
our results our results
so i will start by defining a monotone
distribution
suppose uh we are given a post-it which
is represented by a directed acyclic
graph
on endnotes and we have a distribution q
on the notes of this graph
we say a distribution q is monotone if
for every directed edge from
u to v we have the probability of u is a
smaller than the probability of v
so um now the the goal of
testing monotonicity is as follows we
have
random samples from q which are a set of
vertices
and we are we are given the description
of the posted g so we have full
knowledge of
how the vertices of how the nodes are
connected to each other
and we want to distinguish whether q is
monotone or
epsilon far from monotone in l
distance
why this is an important problem uh
monotonicity is an important structural
assumption
um if we know the underlying
distribution is monotone
we can actually perform several tasks
much more efficient
when we don't have this information for
example entropy estimation
can be done exponentially faster when
when the underlying distribution is
monotone and also
it's the main building block um of
studying the shape of the distribution
so for testing k modality
an important piece is to as to be able
to test
the monotonicity of the distribution
um there are um two sort of
generic and naive results for the upper
bound and the lower bound
the basic upper bound is that you can
just learn the distribution in o of n
um and when you have the distribution
it's pretty much um
it's very easy to test it because you
have the description of the distribution
and there is also a naive lower bound of
the square root n which comes
basically from birthday paradox you
basically need at least the square root
and sample to see
any repeated sample prior to that
you basically see a bunch of unique
elements and um
for most reasonable set of um
process this is impossible uh it's
impossible to
basically test so as these are sort of
the
this is the basically the range of the
sample complexity that we
want to work with prior to our work
many post-its have been considered um
i'm not going to go through the details
of these results but basically what i
want to
emphasize is that the sample complexity
of
this problem has an underlying process
okay um yeah and i forgot to say if you
have any questions
actually i have a question uh can you go
back to the last slide
uh so the n and the boolean hypercube
refers to the size of the dimension of
the hypercube like
uh what would be the testing complexity
for the boolean hypercube
so it's uh so n is the domain size so
for the hypercube it's actually
two to the d or the dimension
so it's actually linear
in terms of the domain so it's like if
if if
at the hypercube is of size of uh
dimension d
it's like two to the dd divided by d
poly log d holly d sorry
um okay
so um let me give you a brief summary of
our results we have
a few upper bounds uh the first one is
um an upper bound of n over log n over
epsilon squared log n
for a matching posit and we also have an
upper bound for a general post-it with
bounded maximum degree which
um as o of d next times n over log n
samples
um we have um
a few lower bounds as well uh uh lower
bound of n over log n for matching
cosets and
um this this is tight given the
results in the previous slide in terms
of n
and using this lower bound we were able
to get a lower bound for hypercube
posted so
here again in the second bullet n is the
size of the hypercube
so think of it as two to the d and by
embedding the heart instance for the
matching problem into some middle layer
of the hypercube we were able to get
an almost linear lower bound for this
problem
and after after our paper um we're
greenfield and
um shows an upper bound of integral
login
for this problem as well for the rest of
this talk i'm going to focus on
the lower band for the matching and um
explain our um the sketch of our proof
for this part
okay uh if there is any question
this might be a good time to ask
could you just go back to the previous
result the how should i interpret this
n to the one minus square root epsilon
for the hypercube
so if epsilon is a constant
it's it's like so basically
this this particle so okay um
we have uh two versions of this um
lower bound if epsilon is a constant
then
obviously we're still far away from um
linear result but we have another result
which says when epsilon is equal to
1 over log
log n to 2.5 i think um
then you get the lower bound of omega of
n
times log n so obviously this this is
not
you know because there is an
interdependence between n and epsilon
this is not
it cannot really interpret it as a
linear lower bound but it basically says
for any distribution that their
dependence to epsilon is not
exponential you get a lower bound of
integral log n like n over poly login
um so it's um but but if you just
um so if x1 is sufficiently small
or if it is one over
poly log n you can do something better
basically
i say thanks but there's another
question
uh from the audience so is there a
post-it note for which the lower bound
is actually known linear lower bound is
there
um
no i think for a while we were thinking
that the hype
might um no actually product even for
the hypercube we know that it
be prior to our work we knew that it's
not the case okay so i
don't know and i think the answer is no
to the best of my knowledge
so thanks
any um and in general if you have
a property that um like for example for
matching
you can actually shuffle the labels and
things pretty much remains the same
for such properties um you can't really
get
like the lower bound is the upper bound
is n over log n
so for some specific structures it may
and
you know that it cannot happen
um um yeah so let me continue to the
sketch of our proof for the
matching for proving the lower bound for
matching
uh to um solve this problem
we introduce a new property we call it a
t
bigness we say a distribution q is a t
big distribution if for every element i
the probability of i according to the q
is at least
one important thing to note about this
property is that it doesn't
it doesn't really care about the labels
of the elements so
if you shuffle the labels of the
elements um
it doesn't change the fact that our
distribution is tb or not
uh we show a reduction from t bigness to
monotonicity and the reduction is simple
um suppose that i want to test the
t bigness of a distribution queue i
create a
distribution p as follows um
a distribution p over imagine as follows
and we have
um n edges on the top on nodes i put the
probability it's of q
i and then the bottom and put
probability of t and um
assign and basically normalize this
setting and assign
um p to basically be this distribution
it is not hard to show that if q is a t
peak distribution obviously p is
monotone
and if q is excellent far from being ta
then p is
tito that's solved far from monotone so
now in a subtracting a lower bound for
the monotonicity problem i can prove all
of them
uh for the tb less problem and it
immediately gives me
the lower bound i want so now we focus
on local bound of n over log n for t b
minus problem
um let me give you um
a plan that we have for proving the
slogan
remember that if we have a if we have a
tb distribution queue
and we draw a bunch of samples from
queue the tester
after receiving this setup sample should
accept should output excel with very
high probability
and on the other hand if i start with
the distribution q prime which is up so
far
from being tbig then the tester should
reject
okay um a plan to prove the lower bound
is to come up with two randomized
processes which i will define later
for generating distributions q and q
prime
such that their sample sets are
indistinguishable if they draw too few
samples
and this gives an immediate lower bound
for the tester because the tester
obviously has to distinguish these two
set of samples okay
so let me um explain what it means to
have
um indistinguishable samples that this
part might be
obvious to the people have seen this
before but
i thought it's important um to talk
about it so the people who are not
uh haven't seen this before me also
enjoy it um so um
so it's important to understand what is
the
information in the samples what is the
informative part
there are several representations for
examples um
we have seen a list and obviously we can
from a list we can actually draw a
histogram so we can
keep track of the frequencies of
each element but as i mentioned um
for t bigness property we don't really
care about the labels of the elements so
we can actually
make this more concise and only care
about
the number of elements that appeared a
certain time
so i'm totally ignoring the labels but
for example in this list there are
three elements that they appeared only
once one element appeared twice
and one element appeared on three times
uh there is another way to base which is
equivalent to this
this one is to basically
um which to basically
uh save the just the number of collision
collisions in the list and what is a k
uh what is a
collisions or k collisions so we usually
say two samples collide if their uh
values are equal so for example the
first sample and the third sample here
they're
both four so it means that they collide
with each other
we say we have a chain wise collision
when i have
when we have k samples that are equal to
each other
in this sample set there is one
three-wise collision which is the
element four that appears three times
and there are four pairs of samples that
are
colliding with each other three of them
comes from
elements of element four and one of them
comes from element one
and we have eight one largest
number of samples we have um
it is known that it's very actually easy
to show that if you
have any of this representation you can
find the other one
up to labels of the elements
but there is this last representation
that
colors in the statistic which has a very
nice property so
the expected value of the k the number
of [ __ ] collusion
is um exactly the case moments of the
distribution
and um so basically
it's a very inaccurate um
statement but basically what you can so
any any set of samples that you have
what you can infer
is the norms of the distribution and
that's pretty much the information that
exists there
um and one thing to note is that when k
is large
then it's harder to um
basically um estimate
uh the moment like obviously if you have
um two repetitions like if the sample
repeated twice it's
much easier than compared to the case
that it happens a hundred times so as
k um gets larger it's harder to estimate
um on the number of conditions
um so if i want to come up with two set
of samples that are indistinguishable
um and one one way to make them
indistinguishable is to match the lower
moments of the distribution so
if i have um so
so basically if i have too few samples
the lower moment seems
uh the lower moment seems identical so
it doesn't give me any information
and the higher moments are basically
invisible i can't i don't even get to
see them so basically
there is no way to distinguish the
samples from q versus the samples from q
prime
and um for the purpose of this talk we
think of the lower moments
as the first log n moments and of the
distribution
so if i say i have a question so you
said
uh histograms and fingerprints they have
this
they information-wise they're the same
they have the same information
as up the labels like it won't
care about the labels of the element yes
so i can't really like yeah so
actually okay and the and then
you're saying if i have the histogram
again like you know with the labels
anonymized and so on
then i can of course extract the ky is
collision statistic
but i can also go in the other direction
that is from the k wise collision
statistic i can also obtain the
histogram
yeah yeah okay and this is the part
where you think that lower order moments
are the only ones which will matter
in this going back
so basically um so if you have cable
explosion you can actually
reconstruct fingerprints and it's
basically you go
into the histogram up to labels yes
and that's why like obviously there are
other ways of coming up with
distributions that are
indistinguishable but one way to think
about it is that
this is all the information that exists
in the in the sample set and i
if i make them equal at least for the
lower moments
then they seem identical in some sense
okay
so um going back to the um
to our scheme for the lower bound i want
to come up with two
randomized processes for q to generate q
and q
prime and um i have a few um
demands here basically i want to make
sure that the q's are t big
q primes are epsilon 4 from t peak and
all of them all of these statements
should hold with high probability and i
want to make sure that
in expectation the moments of q and q
prime are the lower moments of q and q
primes are
identical so let me focus on this
randomized processes and define them how
we actually generate
q and q prime um suppose we have
a distribution p or think of it as
we call it prior and think of it as the
perimeter which we will define later so
this is basically
a set of parameter and um
from the prior distribution p i want to
generate a distribution q
over n elements
uh the way that we generate this
distribution is that by
um we generate n a random variable from
p
and the expected value of these random
variables are
one and um we define the distribution q
to be the vector of these uh random
variables v i's divided by n
and in expectations some
q i's should make the value of each of
those random variables for one
and um in general this this is this may
not be a distribution
uh there are some sudden seals that we
need to take care of but for now
just assume that q is actually a
distribution
um now um
basically my goal is to find two
distribution p and p
prime such that as i mentioned one of
them generates tb
distribution the other one generates up
so far from db distribution
and their sample sets are
indistinguishable so
if i find such p and p prime um
my lower bound is immediate like it's
just
um based on whatever i expected prior to
this point
to find p and p prime what we do is to
basically
formulate nlp i don't want to go through
the
um details of this lp
but basically um i
formulate all the demands that i had i
made sure that the expected value of the
eyes are one
and uh the sen the second um
um um the second uh
line uh the sorry the third line is
basically tells that the
moments of the under the distributions
that are generated match
in expectation and the last line
basically ensures that
the random variables from distribution p
they're
all all of them are certain all of them
are above a certain threshold which
means that they are
they will generate tb distribution and
the
other the other distribution p prime
generates sample
generate samples v i primes such that a
bunch of them are actually zero
and in the objective we want to make
sure at least um
and at least an absolute fraction of
these uh elements are assigned um
basically got the probability zero which
made the distribution far from being too
big
okay so this is dlp
um we um so in a couple of
steps we basically showed that this lp
is eq1 into another lp introduced by
wong yang
and uh roughly speaking if you take the
dual of that
lp it will uh turn into a problem of
um estimating a function with
polynomials uh
below degree polynomials and the low
degree polynomials comes from
the um basically the
the first login moments that we wanted
to match and
uh the solution of that lp comes from
chebyshev polynomials and
um given that their lp has a solution
implies that our lp has a solution so i
have to
um um parameter set of parameters p
and p prime which gives me the lower
bound that i want
so basically this uh um
this is the end of the proof if the pnp
prime exists i know
the lower bound exists
so let me summarize what we talked about
so i give a general overview of
definitions of distribution testing then
we focus on
giving a lower bound for a lower bound
of n over log n samples for
t bigness property which immediately
gives a lower bound for
monotonicity of uh testing volatility of
matchings and
it gives us a lower bound for the
monotonicity of uh testing on the city
of the hypercubes
and uh that's it thank you
thank you marvia we actually have a time
plenty of time for questions
so uh we had a few questions but oh okay
uh yeah i mean there's any um oh is
there
okay yeah so one question we have is is
there an order n over log n upper bound
for the matchings
uh yes yes yeah okay
i it was uh in one of our program that
it's not
um basically the idea is
um at a high level um
the idea is to learn those fingerprints
that i was talking about
and um if you learn that you can
learn so this is
uh so actually i also i did i had
another question i did not quite
understand the reduction between tea
bigness and
that uh because it yeah why are we able
to simulate it
the it's not entirely clever the
reduction if you can
also um
just okay oops
oh i think it was slower
okay so um
so okay so um so i so the input is that
the input is samples from distribution
queue um
but i want to generate the sample from
distribution p
so
so with a probability proportional to n
t
and one i can pick whether to generate
the sample from top or general
just output a uniform sample and if it's
from top you
look at q and ask for a sample how you
generate sample from p
and if p if t if
q is a typic property then this should
be monotone because
after normalization still remain
monotone for h8
will have that property and if it is far
from monotone up to that normalization
um you you are still far from
being modern okay sorry if it's
far from being too big it will be
are there other questions um
i'm trying to do a track of the q a
thing
actually i have another question in the
meantime so um for both sets
there i don't know but there must be
some combinatorial
uh top of combinatorial uh quantities
right something like a width of the
post-it or something like that
and uh is is there any is is there a
property is that you suspect or is there
something known
uh property testing lower upper bound
for testing monotonicity over process
which is naturally related to some
combinatorial quantity
the post-it like the width or something
like that
um or height i don't know like you know
whatever length of the longest chain
number of anti-chains whatever
something like that so okay so um
yeah so these are the ideas that
actually so for i think the previous
uh upper bound or so i think that um
i don't quite remember but there was
another i think there is a
lower there is a lower bound for general
posted and it's a paper
by um
one of the valiants with other people
sorry i don't remember the exact
set of otters but basically what they do
is exactly what you said like they embed
matchings in a post-it and the longer
and
um so basically you need many matchings
many chains and the hope is that to have
longer chains
um so it they have been used um
in different posts
like the transitive closure like for
example we had a
upper bound which worked with the
maximum degree of the transitive closure
so that's also
something that might be interesting but
i don't know if there is
one specific at least i think it's not
known yet
but there is a specific um combinatorial
characterization of the posted which
directs they give you a lower value
uh are there any other questions
okay uh well if not then
uh let's thank mariam and uh
the next talk is by eric i'm not
should i stop uh jesse should i stop the
recording
let's i don't think we need to stop the
recording but we could just start at 11
30. maybe take a little break
okay yeah okay great and we are we are
not doing berkeley time right we are
like doing actual time right
uh oh
i meant are we starting five minutes
after the uh like are we starting five
minutes after the schedule time now
let's keep on the schedule
okay okay okay that's not right okay
okay okay anyway let's take a break and
let's start
uh nine ten sorry what
what time are we at uh 9 30
berkeley pacific time